and it is the oldest starting pitcher in
the game on this day of the schedule or
any other day he's been the oldest
starter in the league this season the
veteran southpaw rich hill six and seven
on the year harper draws a walk and
that'll bring up jt romuto
and rio muto sends that one into left
center field
harper will get to third base easily jt
on his way to second the throw there is
not in time harper will score he never
stop running
one-nothing phillies
one-nothing phillies philly reliever
archie bradley wearing a microphone oh
bryce is gonna go sandal stand up stand
up stand up
yeah
let's go bryce
kyle gibson on the mound for the
phillies last time around was tuesday
against the cubs
and he was perfect through four innings
before really struggling in the fifth
still two balls and two strikes trying
to strand a pair of early base runners
here in the bottom of the first and he
strikes out by his nap adding
right-handed he's at 160 this year walls
in two strikes on nap the pitch swinging
a miss strike three high fastball from
rich hill that's his third strikeout
tonight there's two down in the second
pitch to gibson is popped up
first base side alonzo calling off baez
and pete makes the one-handed catch to
end the inning jd davis leads things off
in the mets half of ending number two
the wind up in the one and two
bouncer towards third charging into
reyes gloves it die high throws on the
run and plenty of time to get davis
gibson
2-1
and a swing and a bouncing ball back to
the mound gibson reaching up that
long-arm frame it's an easy play for him
and he'll throw out mcneal too gone
steps into the wind he
delivers and a swing of the miss nito
goes after one a foot off the plate and
he strikes out third k for gibson one
two three seconds
leads things off in the phillies half of
ending number three snowballs two
strikes the pitch galvez hits one in the
air toward left center pretty deep nimmo
back ranging to his right gets there and
makes the catch
segura's hit safely in 12 of his last
13.
so now bryce harper who walked and
scored the game's only run in the
first got him looking
i think bryce knew it was a strike and
he's like i can't believe that just
happened to me
so here's real mouton now ball two
strikes pitch
swinging to miss strike three rio muto
laid on the fastball from hill two balls
and two strikes to count to lindor
that swung out a miss for strike three
so hill advances so a pass ball
strikeout puts hill at second base with
two gone the pitch
swing of the ground ball left side
diving to reyes he's got it gets up
throws to first he got him amazing play
by ronald teuras diving into the hole
and he takes a hit away from pete alonso
ronald reyes 36 rbis for the philly
third baseman
that's well hit out to left field mcneal
calling for it shy of the track he'll
have room to put it away by the way rich
hill with five strikeouts so far tonight
is the o2
sidearm breaking ball swinging a miss
strike three well knapp offered at it
that was a lackadaisical wave one out
and one on phillies with a one-nothing
lead jd davis is the batter and the
pitch to him swung on bounce back to the
mount gibson's got it throws low to
second pick by segura he'll throw to
first what a play by gene segura as the
phillies turn to a rescue save for
segura well the double play gets written
down it looks routine but it wasn't gene
segura had to make a nifty play at the
second base bag to make that
one to four to three double play happen
and afterwards kyle gibson says thanks
for picking me up that was terrible
a ball and a strike to count to harper
or second and third rather here with one
gun
if they walk him they'll load the bases
for robuto
instead they pitch to harper he sends a
drive out to center field nemo's on a
dead run and he runs it down
both runners tag
two nothing fills
and he leaves with one runner rather
it's his responsibility hoping that jre
spamilla can repeat the performance he
had yesterday
three strikeout to real mucho hard to
argue with the results the best
opportunity yet to break through and get
that zero off the scoreboard and now
it'll be dom smith the pinch hit
that's into the right field corner
and it's gonna score them both
dom smith cashes in off the bench and
the mets have tied it to a piece pete
alonso with the runner at third and two
gone now
[Applause]
chopper to third that's a fair ball for
the reyes
two to tie is what the mets will settle
for in the fifth pitching change for the
mets trevor may gets ending number six
two balls and two strikes pitch
swinging a missed strike three high
fastball as mccutchen
went after 97. beerling has a couple of
base hits swinging a missed strike three
that was another changeup near the top
of the zone trevor may from beltai set
his pitch
swinging a missed right three trevor may
strikes out the side
sagura and harper aboard with two away
real mucho with a bouncing ball to
shortstop lindor goes the short way to
baez and the bases are left loaded in
the top of the seven kyle gibson will
start a seventh inning of work tonight
there weren't any runs scored in the top
of the seventh inning but it was a long
turn on the bench for gibson between
innings of work
mcneal swings and sends a big ball down
to right harper's on the run he looks up
and it's gone
mcneil waits on it watch him wait little
change up this time
doesn't do much right in the wheelhouse
in a big bomb for mcneil in the mets
andrew mccutchen leads things off in the
phillies half of ending number eight
catch punches a bouncing ball to the
right side with luke covering alonso
gets it to him in stride one away one
out nobody on pitch
swing and a miss strike three
basketball by verling two up two down
here in the eighth
miller has never enjoyed his time
against aaron loop overrate with six
strikeouts and a drive into the opposite
field here that chases mcneal into the
corner where he can put it away and diaz
gets out number two and now
bryce harper
nothing but gas from diaz harper sends a
ball to left
mcneal calling for it
and the mets are able to salvage the
series
and snap out of the five-game losing
streak you